Thanks thanks for coming out I
understand there's a lot of baseball
games going on so I appreciate the
audience I'd like to start actually
tonight by reading the two opening
paragraphs of my book and then I'll talk
some more about that it seldom noted but
fear is the first emotion experienced by
a character in the Bible not desire not
shame but fear Adam eats from the tree
discovers he's naked and hides from God
confessing I was afraid because I was
naked before this admission God creates
and sees that his creations are good he
sees that Adam is without a mate which
is not good Eve sees that the tree of
knowledge is pleasant to the eyes and a
tree to be desired to make one wise but
these are reports of antiseptic
perception with no warming murmur of
appreciation or aversion everyone looks
everyone sees does anyone feel not until
they eat from the forbidden fruit do we
hear a felt experience and when we do it
is fear why fear perhaps it is because
for the authors of the Bible fear is the
most electric of emotions prior to being
afraid Adam and Eve exist and act in the
world but without any palpable
experience of it afraid they are awash
in experience with God promising even
more for Eve the pain of childbirth for
Adam the duress of work for both the
dread knowledge of death unafraid Adam
and Eve have only the laziest
appreciation of the good and hazy
establishing
their dim cognizance of evil makes them
spectators to their own lives
semi-conscious actors at best
Adam names Eve succumbs neither really
knows what it is that they do afraid
they know shallow temptation gives way
to dramatic choice inertial motion to
elected action their story our story
is ready to begin after September 11th
2001 writers tell us an altogether
different kind of fear drove a similar
passage from passivity to feeling and
action before 9/11 Americans were
supposed to be in Eden idling in a warm
bath of social autism
according to David Brooks of the New
York Times the ethos of the day was to
cultivate our quote private paradises to
bask in the words of novelist Don
DeLillo in the quote utopian glow of
cyber capital at the time bliss seemed
the glorious glorious flower of peace
and prosperity in fact many claimed it
was the rotting fruit of decadence and
decay suffering no difficulties feeling
no loss we let our sense of the world
grow dim our muscles atrophy holding up
a mirror to our impoverished appetite
for experience
Brooks notes that the most celebrated
sitcom of the age was Seinfeld a show
about nothing but 911 writes Frank Rich
was a quote nightmare
awakening us from a quote frivolous if
not decadent decade-long dream the fear
it provokes provoked adds Brooks was a
morning quote cleanser washing away a
lot of the self-indulgence of the 90s
according to George Packer also of the
New York Times at the time it brought us
it being fear brought us quote alertness
grief resolved even love experience
itself Packer cites approvingly the
comments of an investment banker fleeing
the World Trade Center on the day of the
attack quote I'm not in shock I like
this state I've never been more
cognizant in my life end quote
fear restored to us the clarifying
knowledge that evil exists making moral
deliberate action possible once again
what was to be dreaded was not a repeat
of 9/11 but according to packer
a quote returned to the normality that
she did it for that would mean quote
instead of public memorials private
consumption instead of lines to give
blood restaurant lines instead of civic
attention personal dissolution 9/11 was
not the end of the story
like the saving fear of Adam and Eve it
was just the beginning now I've opened
with these two paragraphs because I
think any discussion about fear and
politics today has to confront one
overriding fact for all the talk in the
media about the Bush administration
manipulating people's fears are playing
politics with people's fears and now to
this week it seems that everybody's now
talking about John Kerry doing the same
we have to recognize that fear is an
emotion that is often welcomed indeed
celebrated by politicians and
intellectuals many of you may have come
here today out of a concern that fear is
doing damage to our country and the
world nevertheless there is a powerful
strain in our culture that sees fear not
as a negative or crippling emotion but
as a positive contribution to moral and
political life not because fear alerts
us to danger not because fear forces us
to confront threats we prefer to ignore
but because fear is supposed to be a
galvanizing emotion a passion that makes
life more exciting more invigorating
more worthwhile now I should say at the
outset in order to clarify that I myself
do not subscribe to this point of view
but it is a view that has wide currency
not just within the Bush administration
or among conservatives but as the quotes
that I've just cited suggest also among
liberals as well the politics of fear in
other words has a deep bipartisan appeal
if that politics is to be opposed or
criticized it must be disinterred at the
roots so I'd like to divide my talk
today into really two parts first I'd
like to examine more carefully this view
of fear as a positive emotion what it
entails what it assumes why people
believe it
and then second I'm going to talk about
what I think the costs of this view of
fear are why it is so profoundly wrong
so how we view fear today and but in the
past though many of us probably believe
that fear is a negative emotion
particularly when it gets mobilized
politically a surprisingly large number
of our leading thinkers from John Locke
the patron saint of modern liberalism to
his conservative counterpart Edmund
Burke have taken the opposite point of
view for these riders and they have many
corollaries in the political world fear
is a positive emotion it arouses a
heightened state of experience it
quickens our perceptions as no other
emotion can it forces us to see and to
act in the world in new and more
interesting ways according to these
writers and their political followers
when things are pleasurable or too easy
we grow lazy we lose our desire to go
out and conquer the world
but when we imagine pain and terror as
Burke Edmund Burke put it we experience
a delightful horror when we are afraid
we are alert and alive eager to take on
the challenges of life without fear we
are passive with fear we are roused to
what Burke called quote the strongest
emotion which the mind is capable of
feeling according to this line of
thinking fear not only rouses us in
these ways it is also supposed to be a
source of civic education of moral and
political instruction when we confront
threats to our political values whether
the threats are Soviet tyranny genocide
in the Balkans or now today Islamic
terrorism we are supposed to learn or
remember the worth of those political
values the fear of Soviet despotism was
supposed to teach us the virtues of
liberal democracy the fear of terrorism
and religious fundamentalism is supposed
to teach us the value of pluralism and
toleration the fear of political danger
in other words forces society to
discover or reduce
political ideals that under less
threatening circumstances might simply
bore it so many intellectuals as well as
leading members of the Bush
administration claimed that before 9/11
we were drowning in a cesspool of
self-satisfaction egoism and consumerism
we lost sight of the meaning of freedom
the value of democracy but after 9/11
they tell us we discovered that freedom
was a fighting faith rather than a cushy
perch weary disc we rediscover the worth
of American democracy
now this appreciation of fear has a very
important corollary at the same time
that writers and leaders see an
opportunity for spiritual renewal and
moral education in the fear of political
danger they insist upon viewing that
danger in other words the object of fear
as not political in other words as
having nothing to do with the issues or
controversies that ordinarily influence
an anime political discussion and action
the threats that inspire fear in other
words do not arise from politics in this
view they arise from somewhere else let
me give you another example from 9/11
according to many commentators what
piloted those planes into the Pentagon
in the World Trade Center was not the
terrorists hostility to u.s. power nor
was it anger at America's patronage of
Israel or its sponsorship of despotic
regimes throughout the Middle East's the
Middle East the 9/11 terrorists
according to these commentators were
simply not interested in politics this
is what Thomas Friedman said Thomas
Friedman in York Times quote their
grievance is rooted in psychology not
politics so what kind of psychological
concerns drove the terrorists to do what
they did on 9/11 according to these
people for some analysts those
psychological concerns were entirely
personal here's what these analysts or
you know more properly psycho analysts
really observed Muhammad Atta the
Egyptian born
leader of the attack attacks sat on his
mother's lap until well after he had
begun college Bottas father claim
complained that his wife raised their
only son as a girl and frequently told
the young muhammad quote toughen up boy
otto stayed away from women right up to
his death his will left very strict
instructions that no women should attend
his funeral
Otto lived in a pink house now Otto's
friends claimed that three things drove
him to do what he did one us support for
the Egyptian government to the Gulf War
and the stationing of American troops in
Saudi Arabia and three the Oslo peace
accords but for the American media and
for many academic theoreticians as well
the real story of 9/11 was contained in
that pink house
otta and this view suffered from a
troubled masculinity 9/11 was the action
of sexually ambiguous boys trying to
prove that they were men for other
analysts the anxiety of the 9/11
terrorists was less personal in the way
that I've just described then cultural
in this view which is held by everyone
from Samuel Huntington and Bernard Lewis
on one end to Thomas Friedman and
Michael Ignatieff on the other end
terrorism is fueled by an anxiety over
the modern world by the march of
secularism and other Western values like
freedom toleration and democracy this
anxiety has nothing to do with power
resources and policy it has everything
to do with the uneasiness of pre-modern
people in the face of modern change
people who are uncertain about the
future according to this line of
argument are right for the totalitarian
logic of Islamic radicalism Allah serves
as a substitute for the lost sense of
authority the terrorist cell becomes a
replacement for a ruined solidarity so
why did the terrorists attack on 9/11
according to this line of argument
because they feared what the United
States represents the modern world with
all its freedom and diversity and
openness
now if it has already not become clear I
and myself rather dubious about both of
these interpretations the first one
about masculine anxiety because to be
honest it describes so many men I
personally know who are not as far as I
know terrorists of any sort and the
second one about cultural anxiety
because if what the terrorists were
really after was freedom openness and
democracy would have seemed to me that a
beggar better target would have been
Sweden Denmark or the Netherlands not
the Pentagon or the World Trade Center
but you need not take this for me
instead I suggest strongly suggest you
read James Fallows article Bush's lost
year in not the current issue of the
Atlantic but the previous issue of the
Atlantic and here's what James Fallows
says quote there may be people in the US
government who have studied fought
against or tried to infiltrate al-qaeda
and who agree with this view this view
that they hate us for who we are I have
never met any the soldiers spies
academics and diplomats I have
interviewed and he's interviewed well
over a hundred people in government and
associated think tanks and so forth are
unanimous in saying that quote they hate
us for who we are end quote
is a dangerous claptrap dangerous
because it is so lazily self-justifying
and self-deluding the only thing we
could possibly be doing wrong is being
so excellent claptrap because it
reflects so little knowledge of how
islamic extremism has evolved now
whether or not you agree with these
cultural or psychological
interpretations of terrorism these
interpretations are emblematic of the
view of fear that i mentioned earlier
where writers and politicians see fear
as a source of civic renewal and moral
and political instruction but that the
condition for their viewing fear in this
way is that they treat the objects of
fear whether the object is 9/11
terrorism or the Soviet Union before
that but they treat those objects as
entirely non-political
this view of fear I which I argue about
and talking about in my book has
extremely deep roots in the Western
intellectual tradition particularly the
modern Western tradition you can see
hints of it in the Bible as I as I
suggested earlier but it really gets
going in the 17th century with the work
of Thomas Hobbes who is a philosopher
responding to the chaos of the English
Civil War and is carried on by various
philosophers throughout the 17th 18th
19th and 20th centuries this view of
fear on the one hand seeing fear as a
source of civic renewal on the other
hand seeing the object of fear as non
political become salient achieves
prominence at particular moments in time
at those moments when we can no longer
agree on the positive moral and
political ideals that should guide us in
public life when we are no longer sure
about the meaning of words like justice
equality freedom we turn to fear as the
answer to our dilemmas and confusion we
may not know what is good or just the
argument goes but we do know what is bad
and evil we may not know what it is to
be happy we do know what it is to be
afraid the reason we know it or at least
the reason we think we know it is that
we assume that fear is not political
that it's an emotion that does not
partake of the controversies and
conflicts that we ordinarily disagree
about if fear were political if we had
to acknowledge that the object of fear
was pullet were political we would argue
about it the way we do about every other
political question and if that would
happen it could not serve as a source of
agreement and renewal by assuming that
it's not political we assume that we
know what it is and why it is bad and
from that almost instinctive you know
visceral knowledge of fear and of danger
we believe we can move forward and
construct a good society as I said this
is a notion that arises at moments of
widespread moral doubt and confusion the
end of the Cold War I would argue with
one such moment of doubt so it's no
accident that riders and politicians
welcomed the fear produced by 9/11
because it provided them an answer to
questions they had been wrestling with
since the collapse of the Berlin Wall
now let me turn to the second half of
the discussion what the costs of this
view of fear are so far I've really been
talking about one type of fear the fear
of foreign or external enemies but in
politics fear always has two faces not
only is there the fear that looks
outward to the enemy a nation confronts
there's also the fear that looks inward
to the domestic inequalities and
hierarchies that a nation sustains this
is the fear that those on the bottom
have of those on the top the fear that
people with power use to intimidate or
suppress those with little or no power
and what I'd like to suggest is what
Thomas Hobbes realized and recognized
long ago that the fear of foreign
enemies is a critical weapon for
creating or exacerbating this domestic
form of fear the fear of foreign enemies
in other words is an instrument of
domestic intimidation for arousing fear
among the lower orders of the higher
orders by welcoming the fear of
terrorism our politicians and
intellectuals have either ignored or
helped justify this conversion of fear
the fear of foreign enemies into the
fear of domestic elites nowhere nowhere
is this conversion more evident than in
the contemporary American workplace
which is an institution that receives
far too little attention from the media
and academia and I'm going to talk about
that now I'd like to explain how this
conversion works but in order to show
that I'd like to first start with
another passage from my book which
describes what I think fear looked like
to many americans before 9/11 in this
overlooked sector of the workplace
a good place to begin an investigation
of intimidation in a contemporary
America is the workplace for it is there
in the under regulated practices of
hiring and firing promotion and demotion
that fear has an especially toxic effect
despite the fact that adult Americans
spend the overwhelming majority of their
waking hours at work and despite the
fact that the business press openly
confesses that quote the workplace is
never free of fear and it shouldn't be
because fear can be a powerful
management tool that's a quote from The
Wall Street Journal the workplace
remains a vast terra incognita protected
from public scrutiny by Hightower's of
legal argument and political
indifference wielding threats of firing
demotion harassment and other sanctions
employers and managers stifles speech
and action ensuring that workers don't
talk back or act up employers do this
not because they are cruel but because
they believe as former Intel CEO Andrew
Grove writes in his aptly titled book
only the paranoid survive that fear
Spurs the fevered pace of contemporary
industry that it's an essential prop of
our political economy workplace fear
creates an internal social order that
can only be described with little
exaggeration as futile a world less
postmodern than pre-modern whose Master
theorist is neither Karl Marx nor Adam
Smith but Joseph de Maistre the counter
revolutionary theorist of the after the
French Revolution consider the
experience of a group of female
employees at a Nabisco plant in Oxnard
California maker of a1 steak sauce and
the world supplier of Grey Poupon
mustard in a 1995 lawsuit these workers
complain that their supervisors
consistently prevented them from going
to the bathroom instructed to urinate
into their clothes or face 3-day
suspension for unauthorized expeditions
to the toilet
the workers opted to wear
diapers but incontinence pads are
expensive so the workers downgraded to
Kotex and toilet paper which posed
severe health risks when soaked in urine
indeed several workers eventually
contracted bladder and urinary tract
infections hearing of their plight
conservative commentator R Emmett Tyrell
jr. advised them to wear special diapers
used by horses in New York's Central
Park carriage trade not until April 1998
did the federal government under
pressure from labor unions even maintain
that employers had to grant employees an
ill-defined quote timely access to the
bathroom in other words it was not until
1998 that there was a federally mandated
right to go to the bathroom when you had
to go since then employers have managed
to evade the law as of 2000 for instance
managers at a Jim Beam biz bourbon
distillery in Clermont Kentucky were
still keeping spreadsheets monitoring
employee use of the bathroom and 45
employees were disciplined for heeding
nature's call outside company approved
break times female workers were even
told to report the beginning of their
menstrual cycles to the human resources
department these are just some of the
most notorious cases of workplace
coercion that have been publicized it's
anyone's guess how many workers how many
more workers excuse me suffer from
similar constraints but are too afraid
to speak out against them in the most
comprehensive survey of employees to
date two social scientists found that
one in five workers considering filing a
lawsuit against their employers did not
do so for feet that their employer would
retaliate against them and in many
states and industries such reprisals are
entirely legal so that's what fear
looked like to people in the United
States before 9/11 the fear of
supervisors and employers what has
happened since 9/11 the fear of
terrorism is now being used to obscure
these domestic forms of entertainment
intimidation with all of our attention
focused on
we don't discuss the concrete fears that
people have of their superiors or and
this is even more worrisome the fear of
intent of terrorism has been used to
justify even to amplify these domestic
forms of intimidation the fear of
terrorism in other words has become
either a distraction or a justification
for the repressive everyday fear of
American life a fear that predated 9/11
and will continue long after the memory
of 9/11 has receded let me just give you
two quick examples example one during
the spring of 2002 shipping companies on
the west coast were facing difficult
contract negotiations with their dock
workers at dock workers unions at the
negotiating table worried about a
possible strike these companies teamed
up with the gap Mattel and Home Depot
which rely on imports from East Asia and
met secretly with the Bush
administration sympathetic to their
concerns the White House declared that
any strike by the dock workers would be
considered a threat to national security
in a fairly lengthy statement Donald
Rumsfeld never explained how stopping
imports of children's toys from the
Philippines or t-shirts from Indonesia
would jeopardize the nation's safety
instead he merely invoked the war on
terrorism and the pending war in Iraq
and said the docks had to stay open that
White House then went on to say that if
the workers struck the government would
respond with a declaration of national
emergency and send in federal troops to
crush the strike the threat worked talk
of a strike ceased the workers
eventually gave in to management most of
management's demands that was example1
example2 well let me just say that so
now that's an example of how the
government uses the fear of terrorism to
enhance intimidation in the private
sector example 2 is an example where the
government uses fear in the private
sector to enhance intimidation in the
public sector this example comes from a
somewhat surprising quarter at least it
was surprising to me in August the New
York Times
courted that the ACLU the American Civil
Liberties Union had promised the
government that it would not employ
anyone appearing on official watch lists
of suspected supporters of terrorism not
convicted terrorists mind you and not
suspected terrorists but suspected
supporters of terrorism whose only crime
might have been to donate money to a
humanitarian group that may or may not
be connected to terrorist activities or
to share a name with someone who had
made such a donation so Teddy Kennedy
the senator from Massachusetts was on
the list as was Georgia Congressman John
Lewis and in one of those bizarre
moments when Kafka becomes comedy the
head of the ACLU Anthony Romero find him
found himself on the list too so why had
the ACLU made this agreement because it
wanted to participate in a government
payroll deduction plan where government
employees are able to make a donation to
nonprofits through their payroll
bi-weekly or monthly payroll checks but
the price for participating in this plan
is that the organization in question has
to agree not to hire anyone on these
government watch lists and I should say
I think there are three of these watch
lists and there's some argument about
whether or not they ought to be
consolidated once the story got reported
the ACLU immediately rescinded its
agreement but it was a small victory as
Romero pointed out on NPR some 2,000
nonprofits including NPR itself
participate in this program with this
last story reveals is a very old and
distinctly distinctively American form
of collaboration between the public and
the private sector after all why did the
government turn to the ACLU and the
nonprofit sector to do these things
because the government lacks the
requisite evidence requisite in terms of
the Bill of Rights to prosecute and
convict certain individuals in court so
what did the government do it turned to
the private sector and had
non-government elites punish these
individuals instead it turned to the one
sphere in our society where coercion is
rampant and constitutional restraint
our minimal the workplace the private
act sector after all is not subject to
the constraints of the bill of rights so
it's the ideal place to do that which
the government could not do the
government in other words outsource
coercion and thereby outsource the fear
that that coercion creates again all in
the name of the fear of terrorism and
I've just asked you if the government's
at the kesariya the country's premier
civil liberties organization has agreed
to participate in this joint venture of
fear you can only imagine what is going
on elsewhere in American society and
other corporations and churches mosques
synagogues and civic organizations now
this as I said is an old story in
American politics the two-way traffic
between the public and the private
sector the collaboration and fear
between the government and civil society
and even parts of civil society like the
ACLU that ought to know better and I say
it's an old story just quick statistic
McCarthyism which we think of Joe
McCarthy and as a primarily a
government-sponsored operation less than
200 people were put in jail for
political reasons during the McCarthy
period almost 40% of the American
workforce on the other hand was subject
to political investigations for their
beliefs in their loyalties McCarthyism
was not primarily a government-run
operation it was very much something
that happened in the workplace as I said
so it's so so old is this kind of
collaboration between the public and
private sector that I give it a name in
my book I call it fear American style so
what has the fear of terrorism
contributed to fear American style it
has enhanced it providing elites with
more ammunition to make their
intimidating presence a fact of daily
life now I could give you a lot more
examples of how this is happening today
but rather than doing that here let me
just encourage you all to read and
better yet buy my book because you'll
find it all there and why don't I stop
there and if you all have any questions
we can talk some more about this so
thank you the
this intensity in the workplace of
repression intimidation don't you think
that followed from massive government
propaganda I mean it started with the
government and then filtered down and
they carried out the agenda but didn't
it start with the government I think
that's true yeah I think it does the
government does take the lead in certain
regards but then again the people in the
workplace is not just a victim of the
government many people in the workplace
profit from that kind of propaganda and
make use of it I don't know what what
it's like in Chicago in New York if you
walk around any Starbucks you'll find
all kinds of pamphlets for how to
protect yourself and what to do in the
event of emergencies now why is
Starbucks getting involved in this kind
of level of which what seems to me basic
fear-mongering because the kind of
information that's there is is either so
obvious and banal everybody knows it
already or it just sort of inflates the
level of hysteria so I don't think the
government is mandating that that that
Starbucks do that but I mean I agree
with you I think the it begins with the
government I mean there is no other
institution that possesses that kind of
you know political resource to mobilize
society but Society you know the the
workplace and corporations they get in
on it because it's it's it's good
business oftentimes it's good you know
there's money to be made there
you mentioned the the reasons for the
for 9/11 now according to many people
now you quote a Brooks Ignatieff and
Friedman three right-wingers who were
pro war yeah now many analysts foreign
journalist Gabriel Kolko is one of them
Greg Palast I guess is local and there
are others who maintain that that was an
attack against globalization the
Pentagon was a target and I'm not sure
what the other one was but it was an
attack on American foreign policy on
globalization what's your response to
that well let me just make clear
something when I was quoting those
people I I hope it was clear that I
myself do not agree with them I think
those interpretations that people like
Brooks and Ignatieff and all the rest of
them offer are specious I think they're
absolutely wrong you know Thomas
Friedman well he himself seems to half
the time admit that he's wrong and
changing his mind on the daily basis so
I completely disagree with it I think
it's a complicate an expert on
middle-east terrorism so in some ways
I'm probably not the best person to
answer your question it's a good one I
think that's what all the people are
wrestling with from what I've seen it's
a combination of factors it's a
combination of American foreign policy
absolutely as you write it's a
combination of the support that the
United States has offered both to the to
the State of Israel and also to a lot of
repressive regimes in the Middle East
those seem to be some of the key factors
the thing that I do believe is that it's
a response to policies it's not it's
it's a response to reality in the world
it's not a kind of private hallucination
of young boys and nor is it a collective
cultural hallucination of a bunch of
fanatics it's much you know and what
makes me say that is if you read
Imperial hubris you know by anonymous
he's very clear on this topic this is
the guy who was the the expert on
al-qaeda in the CIA and he's absolutely
clear that this is fundamentally a
policy question so I think that
a lot of what these journalists and
intellectuals sort of freelance
intellectuals out there it's just a lot
of heavy breathing frankly that it's not
seriously engaging with the fundamental
questions but I let me add one more
thing they come from a long tradition
these guys they're not just
right-wingers they come from the
mainstream of modern social thought and
that's part of the argument of the book
is that if you actually read this sort
of history of intellectual thought and
political thought in some ways the way
these guys responded to 9/11 is no
surprise at all because this has been a
tendency that has been developing over
an extremely long time so yeah I'm sorry
I missed the first part of your talk so
you may have actually covered this
already what benefits does a government
get when its population is living in
fear and what does that population lose
well I think you have to specify what
government we're talking about it
depends on the food
well but even if it's very clear what
the Bush administration and what the
Republican agenda gets from a population
that's living in fear
number one the easiest and foremost
thing is they clearly are banking that
they're gonna win this election on that
basis I mean they are putting everything
into winning this election on that basis
they've made it and there's nothing
there should be nothing surprising about
that back in January of this year the
New York Times reported a quote from a
high-level official in the bush
re-election campaign who said that the
centerpiece of the Bush agenda would be
what they called the quote fear factor
they've been very upfront about this
from the start but I think in some ways
to focus merely just on the election is
to really miss much deeper levels of
policy that's where I think the real
issue gets going I gave you a couple of
examples let me just talk about within
the government itself one that I did not
talk about the Department of Homeland
Security has a bureaucracy of about a
hundred and seventy thousand employees
when that when that department was
formed there was a big issue you might
remember it about whether or not the
employees in that department would have
unionization and civil service rights
some of these are
that go back to basically the
administration of Abraham Lincoln I mean
they go there a long time and there was
a big struggle about that and the
Republicans and the Bush administration
absolutely insisted that they should not
have those rights because and this is a
quote from Tom Ridge we have to be as
quote agile as the terrorists themselves
so in the name of national security
these people have to be stripped of all
these rights and protections 170000 now
a couple of things should be pointed out
number one many of these people are in
clerical support staff position
janitorial the whole realm of people who
are not involved directly in national
security and their counterparts in the
defense department all have union and
civil service protections so if the
Defense Department which you know
managed to make it through the Cold War
could manage to have employees with
those kinds of protections I think we
can easily dismiss the security argument
but and here's where I think this gets
the rub of the whole thing is after the
bill was passed and I should add it was
passed right after the November 2002
midterm election when the Democrats
still controlled the Senate by a very
tiny tiny majority but he passed under
the Democratic watch after it passed
mitch daniels who's the head of the OMB
at the bush administration said that
this is now a model with what we've done
in homeland security is a kind of test
case or model for what we want to do
throughout the government in other words
they want to completely get rid of all
unions out of the government and this is
not just a sort of human rights issue
the public sector is the one area where
unions have managed to hold a foothold
you know keep a foothold in the time
when union membership is declining so
they very clearly see this as a way of
revamping and restructuring the whole
nature of the federal government they
also use these sorts of argument to get
fast-track Authority right after 9/11
zola the Trade Representative basically
made it very clear he said that the
anti-global is this gets back to your
question the anti-globalization movement
and al-qaeda you know that they have
intellectual this intellectual currents
running between the two and they use
that argument in order to get fast-track
passed for the president so there's a
whole level of policy
that the Bush administration is
conducting and pursuing all in the name
of fear so you say who does it benefit
that government it absolutely benefits
them they wouldn't these are not stupid
people they have many sins but stupidity
is not one of them and they know exactly
what they're doing the people the other
half of your question I don't think it
no I don't think it benefits people at
all I mean I think you know I to be
honest with you I think this whole issue
has become a three-ring circus in this
country I mean look at Europe they've
been dealing with terrorism for decades
they have not let it turn their country
their society into this kind of Gothic
funhouse that we live in I mean I just
want to be clear about this there is a
real threat of terrorism there's no
doubt about that but in some ways I
think this is what John Kerry who I'm
not a big supporter of at all but I
think he was sort of getting at in that
magazine piece in The Sunday Times a few
weeks ago and he said let's get it to
the level of a nuisance I mean that's
exactly what Europe did and the fact
that the Bush administration has just
gone screaming suggests they don't want
it to be at that level they like they
like it for a wide variety of reasons to
be at a fever pitch and that's what has
to be opposed I think
okay oh yes I just wanted did you do
much research into the Wilson
administration and the attempts that
they made and their propaganda
indoctrination to get us into World War
one I don't talk about that at all in
the book it's a it's a very internment
it's the classic examine public
relations of modern propaganda in the
United States and yeah no I mean Walter
Lippman a whole group of people come out
of that experience really thinking about
John Dewey about the nature of demócrata
merican democracy I know some about it
but I didn't write about it but no it's
an another excellent situation which has
a lot of parallels not only the
propaganda and the inflation and the
inflation of rhetoric on the one hand
but then the crushing of the labor
movement and other left-wing movements
in the United States at the same time I
mean the two go hand-in-hand these are I
mean I call these the two faces of fear
one looks outward to an enemy the other
looks inward to the sort of domestic
arrangements of power and in some ways
the hero of this book is this English
philosopher from the seventeenth century
Thomas Hobbes who's an unlikely hero but
that's exactly the kind of society he
envisioned in his book Leviathan where
you know in the name of protecting you
from all sorts of enemies you have a
ruler who rules with an iron fist in a
certain way and he said the the end of
all obedience is protection that was his
the end of all obedience in other words
this is what you this is why we obey is
to be protected but that's the price of
obedience so it might seem like an
obscure reference but in many ways I
think he's probably the most preeminent
philosopher of our time because he's in
some ways predicts the kind of world
that we actually are inhabiting today
Wilson's administration and his
followers termed african-americans
pro-german in other words if there were
complaints if there was protests they
returned or German in fact during his
administration think 1917 was one of the
and that year there are more people
hanged lynched more blacks lynched then
any other year and some people credit
that to his propaganda hmm
and turn against the civil rights
movement yeah interesting I wonder if in
your book if you commented on
Roosevelt's famous line and you cover
that and then also I wonder if maybe you
have a comment about the culture of fear
in the United States and especially like
maybe perhaps like in Fahrenheit 9/11
Michael Moore Michael Moore talks about
how you know he can or goes ball way
back to a Civil War era and America is
afraid of the slaves right authorizing
somebody getting guns right and things
like that and yeah condoms okay I do
talk about the FDR quote the only thing
we have to fear it's fear itself just
too sorry I'm trained as a political
philosopher so I always have to give you
the genealogy of the history of these
quotes that actually he got it from
Thoreau who has a similar line in one of
his I bleed it's one of his Diaries he
was while he was composing the the first
inaugural that was sitting there in his
hotel room Thoreau got it from Montana
the French essayist who wrote I remember
the exact quote but it's in the book in
one of his essays he actually has an
essay on fear and this was I think 1571
1572 so there there was a time when
American presidents were quoting people
who were quoting other people in that
way so I do talk about that and I also
talk about it in a weird way I think
there's two ways to read that quote one
is it's a very forthright statement of
hope you know that we have to reject
feeder in some kind of way that rather
than taking the path of fear we have to
take the path of resistance to fear
that's one way of reading and I think
that's the way it's traditionally been
read I think there's another way of
reading it which it's a little bit in
the story that I'm talking about
what but he's essentially saying is is
that fear itself is debilitating is
crippling in all these ways but the fear
of fear itself
is renewing and in opposing that kind of
fear I think he fits in more within the
mainstream of modern thought that I laid
out there but I think you can sort of
play with it and it's a very rich quote
and can be used in all sorts of ways and
and has all sorts of meanings but your
second question I think you were asking
about Bowling for Columbine yeah which I
thought I liked better than I liked
Fahrenheit 9/11 because I thought that
he actually more got into two issues
that I think are quite relevant in the
United States one is the issue of race
and that the issue of fear I mean that
it's probably I think there's a couple
of different kinds of fear in this
country but I think the fear of African
Americans on the part of white America
is is one of the original ones going
back to slavery and also the fear of
African Americans of white Americans
comfort I mean it's it's a two-way
street back and forth one is a group of
people without power of people with
power and the others of people with
power of people without power that's the
way these fears oftentimes work the
people with power oftentimes just as
afraid of the people without power
because they're terrified that they're
gonna rise up and dispossessed that in
fact if Martin Luther King who we don't
think of as being a particularly you
know having a particular aggressive
vision of the United States was very
clear on this subject who's very clear
on the fear of white America of black
America and it was a fear of
dispossession so I think he handles that
I think he gets into that issue and the
other issue is the issue of the welfare
state because this is connected with the
issue of the workplace one of the
reasons why Americans have to endure the
kind of oppression in the workplace that
we endure which I should say is really I
think without parallel in any of the
other Western European or other
industrial kind of democracies that I
mean we in this country have in a regime
in the workplace that is really like no
other and for long historical reasons
but one of the reasons we put up with it
is that we have no safety net there's no
cushion how can you oppose us you know
an employer when you know if you if you
quit or a fired for insubordination
there's no unemployment
there's nothing there's no health
insurance for you so of course Americans
have to put up with it so I thought he
did that quite well
he gives concreteness to the kinds of
fears that American have Americans have
as opposed to many analysts who sort of
painted as a sort of vague
phantasmagoria what's wrong with America
there's good reasons why people in the
United States are afraid because it's
historically rooted okay
well thanks very much for coming and